de monsieur raymond couderc à monsieur
me chargé des transports de la mairie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à la suite
des préconisations de la commission
mobilité 21 le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer que le tronçon de ligne à
grande vitesse montpellier perpignan
qui est un minuscule chaînon de 130 km
sur le corridor numéro 6 entre
amsterdam madrid et séville que ce
tronçon donc été reportée après 2030 le
premier ministre justifier cet été ce
choix en évoquant l'intérêt du citoyen
et l'intérêt des territoires c'est une
décision difficilement acceptable tant
pour nos partenaires espagnols qui ont
fait de lourds investissements et ont dû
payer au delà de 150 millions d'euros
d'indemnités compensatoires pour n'avoir
pas respecté les engagements du traité
de concession
que pour les collectivités concernées du
languedoc-roussillon qui ont déboursé
pas moins de 20 millions d'euros pour
financer le débat public et les pré
études en décalage total avec ce report
le ministre transports a déclaré vouloir
poursuivre les études en cours sur la
lgv montpellier perpignan or ces travaux
sont coûteux et il n'y a aucune
visibilité réelle sur le calendrier du
projet puisque le gouvernement n'a pas
validé les résultats du comité de
pilotage qui s'est tenue le 8 octobre
2012 à montpellier et n'a pas permis le
lancement des études préalables à la des
huées
la situation doit impérativement être
précisés car au final il serait beaucoup
plus onéreux de reporter de 10 ans un
projet qui est déjà lancée que de le
poursuivre en conservant les dates
initiales en effet il est quasiment
certain que les études entreprises
aujourd'hui soit caduc dans 10 ans et
doivent être alors entièrement reprise
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai réuni
le 10 octobre tous les acteurs français
et espagnols concernés par la ligne à
grande vitesse montpellier perpignan à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
afin d'appeler ensemble le gouvernement
à clarifier sa position
et à redéfinir un calendrier adapté à un
projet hautement stratégique pour
l'avenir de nos régions aussi encore une
fois devant notre assemblée je réitère
cet appel sachant que de leur côté les
responsables politiques et économiques
de catalogne espagnole sont ulcérés par
la décision française monsieur le
ministre sur le corridor numéro 6 entre
amsterdam et madrid il ne manque que ce
petit tronçon de 130 km l'union
européenne est prête à cofinancer à 40%
ce projet car elle juge prioritaires les
liaisons transfrontalières et ça nous a
été confirmée la semaine dernière il
faut que le gouvernement prenne en
compte cette priorité et lancer la
procédure de déclaration d'utilité
publique et travaux dans la foulée je
vous remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole et à monsieur benoît hamon
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur couleur je vous ne reprit à
nouveau d'excuser l'absence de frédéric
cuvillier actuellement en déplacement
avec le président de la république en
afrique du sud je vous confirme ce que
vous savez déjà la commission mobilité
21 en effet retenu en seconde priorité
le projet de ligne nouvelle montpellier
perpignan
il faut rappeler que la mission confiée
à la commission mobilité 21 qu'on peut
consister à proposer une hiérarchisation
des grands mots projet compte tenu de
l'impasse financière à laquelle a abouti
le schéma national des infrastructures
de transport qui est avait été élaboré
par le précédent gouvernement mais qui
promettait notamment et de façon assez
irresponsable le lancement d'une
quinzaine de lgv dans les 20 prochaines
années sans que l'on sache comment les
financer simultanément il était
nécessaire donc de hiérarchiser la
commission mobilité 21 a fait ce travail
il faut rappeler également que le
précédent gouvernement a lancé le
chantier de 4 lgv en même temps dont le
contournement de nîmes montpellier alors
que le rythme habituel était d'une lgv
tous les six ans s'agissant plus
particulièrement du projet de ligne
nouvelle montpellier perpignan
la commission a considéré que son
engagement pouvait intervenir à partir
de 2030 vous l'avez vous même rappelé à
l'instant pour autant frédéric cuvillier
souhaitez vous apporter les éléments de
précision suivent les priorités
nationales définies par le gouvernement
sur les bases des recommandations de la
commission mobilité 21 n'ont pas
vocation à figer définitivement la
planification des infrastructures de
transport elles seront actualisés tous
les cinq ans pour tenir compte des
nouvelles dynamiques territoriales de la
saturation du réseau
existant et tirer les conséquences de la
reprise de la croissance d'ici là les
études et procédures des projets
d'infrastructures nouvelles retenues par
la commission mobilité 21 doivent donc
être poursuivi l'objectif est que ces
projets soient prêts à être lancés dès
que leur financement a été stabilisé
concernant la ligne nouvelle montpellier
perpignan il s'agit de poursuivre les
études de tracé en partenariat avec les
collectivités locales afin de définir un
projet pouvant être soumis à une enquête
d'utilité publique par ailleurs sur les
30 milliards d'euros de grands projets
qui seront engagés d'ici 2030 deux
milliards d'euros sont prévus pour
permettre en tant que de besoin
l'anticipation avant cet horizon de
premiers travaux en lien avec certains
projets classé en seconde pro brio rites
et par la commission et notamment le
projet de ligne nouvelle montpellier
perpignan des observatoires de trafic et
de la saturation vont également être
créé pour éclairer l'ensemble des
partenaires concernés sur les
perspectives de réalisation de certains
projets l'axé ferroviaire languedocien
donc le projet de ligne nouvelle est
concerné par ce dispositif je vous
remercie merci monsieur couderc
mais je vis je j'ai dit il ya quelques
instants que les collectivités locales
s'étaient déjà engagées au niveau de 20
millions d'euros pour les études qui ont
eu lieu jusqu'à maintenant et évidemment
si on continue les études dans l'est
les années qui viennent et que les
travaux ne sont pas entrepris dans la
foulée il est fort probable
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
que ces études soient devenues caduques
étant donné l'évolution de la
réglementation de la législation que ces
études soient devenus caducs en 2030
donc c'est de l'argent qui risque d'être
jetés par les fenêtres et donc nous
avons besoin est le plus vite possible
d'une certitude quant à l'enchaînement
des études et de la développer et des
travaux pour être certain de ne pas
gaspiller l'argent public
collègues ainsi monsieur ministre et
coûteux